but
looks like a grandma's there
[Music]
or something along those lines
anyway we're getting e4 and the rat
didn't work out the last game but i
don't think it was due to the opening
so i'll just repeat it
like i don't really think you can go
bishop d3 and really
expect to be
to be doing great from the opening
okay h4 it's quite interesting
i guess i'll just stop him in his tracks
and i have a fairly nice outpost
on g4 so i don't think i should complain
hp3 and then knights and six
yeah i feel like i'm doing doing
very well after the opening here
um it'll take on f3
then i'll go e6
and uh i have a bit of an unpleasant
threat here after e6 doesn't actually
really matter which one he
recaptures with um
i have an unpleasant threat which is to
go with cd4
i don't think she really uh
addressed his that's wrath by by his
last move
uh yeah cd4 bishop b4 was the problem
but now there are a lot of weaknesses in
the white position
and i don't really think
you can play like this with impunity
i think
even the way that i'm playing today
yeah this play deserves punishment okay
so we decided to give up
give up a pawn in order to
um to limit the damage which i guess
it's a reasonable decision
but still i have a very very sound extra
pawn
i was hoping you were hoping you
wouldn't find that
yeah i know i don't have that much to be
found
at least i can go rook c8 because bishop
on h6
covers square on c1
so i can't impose the rook but yeah
after a later
d5 i don't have i don't have that much
brook h3 rook d3 is a nice maneuver
or even like this i think i'll go b5 and
then a5
the bishop is sitting very pretty on b3
so i have to
try and harass it okay a4 this one will
be pretty happy to see
now i'm getting probably there wasn't
wasn't a good choice there because d5 a4
was trapping the bishop for
what i think is an insufficient
compensation
but also what he played doesn't look
doesn't look that great add some tricks
here like we should see one intending
rook d4 and then if rook a2
i can go rookie two i can go bishop
i can go uh
i go rook before and then bishop b3 so i
don't actually get
i should be two there it's a bit
disappointing
okay i'll go i'll go rook before
immediately
and um rook v8 just trying to
harass this bishop a little bit a little
bit more i should say
okay yeah bishop d1 then i think i'll
just
um move over again
yeah he's defending he's defending
pretty well here
i guess i'll try and bring the bishop
into the game
rook d8 at least i'm winning d4
i don't think uh this counterplay that
he has is too dangerous
now they can help him kg7
and i use this of course but still i got
bishop c3 next i should win another pawn
and that [ __ ]
should be the game
don't want to exchange rooks so i'll go
bishop i'll go rook b5 and if bishop c4
i got 65 and king f4 there's fish e5
and uh with two extra pawns there should
be plain sailing
uh yeah he's defending
defending well for the moment i guess
i'll go here rook a3
try and uh poke
a little bit now
h4 should be falling although i have to
play a bit faster
okay
uh yeah a little bit slow
but i guess after all a comfortable
enough game
you just played he just played really
really poorly in the opening there i
don't know
really what that was all about